the y2k bug the release of Destiny's
Child say my name and the launch of the
PlayStation 2 the year 2000 was pretty
big if you want to revisit the dawn of
the second millennium then good knows
your PlayStation 4 will soon be able to
play those beloved ps2 classics I'm Dave
and welcome to a GameSpot news update
Sony is working on emulation technology
that will allow PlayStation 2 games to
be played on its latest home console the
PlayStation 4 the news was revealed in
an email statement sent to Wired you're
working on utilizing ps2 emulation
technology to bring PlayStation 2 games
forward to the current generation said
unnamed Sony representative we have
nothing further to comment at this point
in time in January 2014 an anonymous
source working on Sony's PlayStation now
streaming technology said an emulator
was in the works the ps4 that would run
ps2 games in native high-definition
resolutions as a result this would offer
a visual advantage over the previously
existing PlayStation 1 and PlayStation 2
upscaling methods
it appears the ps2 emulation has
recently been the subject of technical
tests on November 19th alongside the
release of EA and dices Star Wars
Battlefront the publisher also released
star wars racer revenge Star Wars Jedi
Starfighter and Star Wars bounty hunter
all classic ps2 titles in addition to
various visual improvements and remapped
controls of the re-releases also include
trophy support it's possible that these
were added through a method outlines in
a paintin that Sony applied for in 2013
Sony has also previously painted a
technology for adding content to
emulated games October 26 Sony sends out
a survey asking PlayStation 4 users what
they think are the most important
features that should be added to the
console among the options was PSone
classics and ps2 classics support
indicating the platform holder may be
gauging the demand for more re-releases
swot platinum ps2 titles are you looking
forward to revisiting let us know your
favorites in the comments section below
or you can find me on twitter at a
regular dave and for more on all the
latest gaming news in nostalgia make
sure to stay tuned in to GameSpot calm
you